Well, to start off, 0 is the coordinate of any x-intercept. So if we plug in 0
for x in our equation, we get f of 0 equals a to the 0. Now, if I take any
number that a could equal to the 0 power, then we get 1 for f. That means that
the y-intercept of any exponential function of this form, whether it's growing
or decaying is 0, 1. That's really cool. Bringing it back to decimals again,
I've started us off with the function f of x equals 2 to the x. And we can see
that, yes, in fact, our y-intercept is at 0, 1. As we slide a, either making it
bigger or making it smaller, the one point that never changes is the 0.01. You
can watch the rest of the curve flip right around that point. It's almost like
a pivot point.